Buonasera.
Buonasera. Siamo di nuovo qui. Quest'anno raccontiamo le tre guerre di indipendenza. Ero incerto se dirvi subito che la prima è la più lunga di tutte. È lunga, complicatissima da raccontare, per cui faremo l'una di notte stanotte, ma in compenso le prossime saranno più veloci.
Grazie.
E' sempre qualcosa di fortemente legato allo spazio, condizionato dallo spazio, le guerre in generale.
Ma le tre guerre di indipendenza italiane sono state condizionate dallo spazio della geografia della pianura padana in un modo impressionante. Vi ricordo una cosa che sapete tutti.
Noi abbiamo perso, dico noi, ma insomma, la battaglia decisiva della prima guerra di indipendenza nel 48 in un posto chiamato Custoza.
E siamo riusciti a perdere, 18 anni dopo, la battaglia decisiva della terza guerra di indipendenza di nuovo a Custoza.
Ora, uno dice, con 8.000 comuni che ci sono in Italia, e invece non è un caso, perché la geografia della pianura padana incanalava i movimenti degli eserciti.
E Custoza, che se ne sta al di là del Mincio, proprio all'altezza dei ponti, che un esercito dell'epoca doveva usare per forza, se voleva passare il Mincio e invadere il Veneto, Custoza era predestinata a essere un luogo dove gli eserciti si sarebbero scontrati.
Il condizionamento geografico, dunque, dipende da come è fatta la pianura padana, che se ci pensate, è spaccata in due dal Po, va bene.
Il Po all'epoca, anche adesso, non è facile da passare per un esercito in guerra, all'epoca era molto difficile da passare, o si stava su o si stava giù di solito.
Le tre guerre di indipendenza, qual è il tema? Un esercito che viene da Occidente e che vuole invadere il Lombardo-Veneto.
I piemontesi nel 48, i piemontesi e i francesi, che per fortuna sono venuti a dare una mano, se no non ce la facevano neanche quella volta lì, nel 59.
Nel 66 cambia poco, gli italiani hanno già la Lombardia, ma bisogna sempre invadere il Veneto, quindi la direzione è sempre quella.
E il Lombardo-Veneto sta a nord del Po, all'ingrosso. Quindi tu ti muovi da Occidente a nord del Po e cosa incontri?
Fiumi, uno dopo l'altro, che vengono giù e sfociano nel Po. La Sesia, il Ticino, l'Adda, l'Oglio, il Mincio.
E tutti questi fiumi, attraversarli con un esercito, non è per niente facile. I ponti sono pochi, le strade sono quelle che sono.
E quindi lo spazio condiziona le operazioni militari come più ancora che in qualunque altra guerra, forse.
Allora, detto questo, la guerra del 48. Premetto che vi racconto solo quella del 48, non la ripresa del 49, quando Carlo Alberto ci ha riprovato,
perché se no facevamo le due di notte. Quindi noi ci accontenteremo della sconfitta nella prima, che è già molto istruttiva, come vedrete.
La guerra del 48, che scoppia in quell'anno che ai contemporanei sembrò un anno pazzesco, non avevano mai visto un anno del genere.
L'anno in cui il mondo va a gambe all'aria. Tanto che poi generazioni e generazioni continuano a dire
è successo un 48, hanno fatto un 48. Perché nel 48 veramente sembrava che andasse il mondo sotto sopra.
Tutta l'Europa è attraversata dalla rivoluzione. Tutti i popoli contestano i loro governi chiedendo più libertà
e l'Italia, che è parte dell'Europa, c'è in pieno in questo movimento, anzi è all'avanguardia.
In Sicilia la rivoluzione del 48 comincia già a gennaio e già il 29 gennaio
il re di Napoli, Ferdinando II, concede la Costituzione.
Notate, la Costituzione è quello che tutti questi popoli in tumulto chiedono.
Uno dice la Costituzione, ma quale Costituzione? Come sappiamo ce ne possono essere tante, si possono cambiare.
Ma lì il problema non è quello. Il problema è che prima Costituzioni non ce n'erano proprio.
Le monarchie assolute non hanno bisogno di Costituzione, perché il re fa tutto quello che vuole.
Ci mancherebbe che ci dovesse essere lì della roba scritta che obbliga il re a fare certe cose e non farne certe altre.
Quindi, sì, non è che non gli importasse cosa mettere nella Costituzione,
ma la cosa decisiva era innanzitutto avercene una.
Il re che concede una Costituzione dice
io non sono più un sovrano assoluto.
Regno per volontà di Dio, per grazia di Dio, ma anche per volontà della nazione.
Dunque, gennaio Sicilia.
A febbraio la rivoluzione investe il paese che in Europa è specializzato in rivoluzioni,
la Francia. E i francesi, naturalmente, fanno le cose molto sul serio.
Loro non si accontentano della Costituzione.
Buttano giù la monarchia di Luigi Filippo e fanno la Repubblica.
A quel punto, anche l'altro re italiano,
in Italia ci sono il Papa, gli austriaci nel Lombardo-Veneto,
vari principi e duchi, ma due re.
I Borboni al sud e i Savoia al nord, al nord-ovest, Piemonte e Liguria.
Allora, il primo re Ferdinando di Borboni l'ha già data la Costituzione.
Dopo che la rivoluzione scoppia anche a Parigi,
Carlo Alberto, re di Sardegna, decide che effettivamente forse il futuro sta da quella parte.
Forse conviene accettare questa spinta, questa richiesta dei popoli.
Carlo Alberto concede, poi alla fine un piccolo ripensamento.
Dice, però non la chiamiamo Costituzione, la chiamiamo Statuto.
Ci avete mai pensato?
No, perché uno dice lo Statuto del 48, lo Statuto Albertino,
ma non la chiamano Costituzione perché Costituzione è una parola troppo di sinistra.
Così la cosa sembra meno dura da ingoiare.
E poi, quindi marzo, 4 marzo, e poi succede l'impensabile.
La rivoluzione scoppia nel cuore dell'impero austriaco.
La rivoluzione scoppia a Vienna.
Anche a Vienna il popolo, gli studenti, chiedono che sia cacciato il vecchio principe Metternich,
che governa l'impero da 30 anni e che siano date libere elezioni, un parlamento, una costituzione.
E l'imperatore cede.
Promette ai suoi popoli che verrà convocato un parlamento
che rappresenterà tutti i popoli dell'impero austriaco.
Istantaneamente la rivoluzione scoppia in tutte le altre province dell'impero.
Il 15 marzo scoppia a Budapest, dove si proclama l'indipendenza dell'Ungheria.
Il 17 marzo scoppia a Venezia, dove si proclama la Repubblica di San Marco,
che non era poi un tale vecchiume all'epoca, erano passati solo 50 anni,
c'era chi se la ricordava ancora.
Il giorno dopo, 18 marzo, Milano.
Dove non hanno nessuna cosa specifica da chiedere nel passato,
non sono mai stati capitale di niente,
però comunque chiedono l'autonomia per il Lombardo-Veneto.
E chiedono che il governo imperiale ritiri dalla guarnigione di Milano
i reggimenti stranieri e lasci soltanto i reggimenti reclutati in Italia.
Il comandante militare austriaco del Lombardo-Veneto,
Radetzky rifiuta.
E a Milano scoppia la rivoluzione.
Il 19 marzo Radetzky fa rapporto a Vienna.
La città di Milano è sconvolta dalle fondamenta
ed è difficile farsene un'idea.
Il carattere di questo popolo mi sembra cambiato come per un colpo di bacchetta magica.
Il fanatismo ha pervaso ogni età, ogni ceto, ogni sesso.
Sono le cinque giornate di Milano evidentemente.
Solo che quando noi in italiano diciamo le cinque giornate di Milano
c'è un po' il rischio che ci faccia l'effetto.
Sì, vabbè, è una cosa che sappiamo, la sappiamo fin da bambini.
Ogni tanto arriva uno sceneggiato televisivo a riproporla.
Ci sono le barricate, gentiluomini in cilindro e popolani col berretto,
affratellati dietro le barricate.
Dall'altra parte gli austriaci in giacca bianca.
Tutti questi giovanotti con barba e baffi pieni di entusiasmo.
Le ragazze che gli portano da mangiare dietro le barricate.
Ecco, questa visione oleografica delle cinque giornate di Milano
non è che sia sbagliata, ma non deve nasconderci
quello che vuol dire davvero la rivoluzione
in una città di 160.000 abitanti
che aggredisce la guarnigione straniera di 14.000 uomini
armata fino ai denti per sterminarla
e secondariamente cacciarla dalla città,
ma possibilmente sterminarla.
Le cinque giornate di Milano non vuol dire
solo le barricate, vuol dire
il giovanotto barbuto che sbuca all'improvviso
da un portone con un coltellaccio
e sgozza il soldato austriaco
che è rimasto isolato dai suoi,
vuol dire i soldati che irrompono nelle case
da cui si spara
e ammazzano a baionettate tutti quelli che trovano dentro,
vuol dire le migliaia di morti per la strada.
I milanesi hanno avuto qualche centinaio di morti,
gli austriaci hanno avuto 4.000 morti,
4.000 cadaveri per la strada
in una Milano piccolissima
che va dal castello Sforzesco a Porta Romana,
morti ammazzati in combattimento
e magari anche morti perché fucilati.
Carlo Cattaneo,
che è membro del governo provvisorio a Milano,
l'unico membro di sinistra del governo provvisorio,
Carlo Cattaneo si vanta,
noi milanesi non ammazzavamo i prigionieri,
gli austriaci invece sì,
gli austriaci fucilavano tutti i prigionieri
presi con l'arma in mano.
L'odio che attraversa le strade di Milano
in quei cinque giorni
è una cosa che noi oggi facciamo fatica a immaginare,
l'odio etnico contro i tedeschi
perché la tragedia che dilania l'impero osburgico
è che c'è una nazionalità, quella tedesca,
gli austriaci di lingua tedesca
che domina e vuole dominare gli altri
e tutti li odiano.
Radetzky è visto come quello che incarna
un sogno di supremazia tedesca nell'impero
col suo stato maggiore, dice Carlo Cattaneo,
di teutomani,
di fanatici della supremazia teutonica,
il che poi non impedisce agli italiani
di disprezzare dall'altra parte
quell'esercito bastardo
in cui si parlano dieci lingue
perché l'esercito dell'impero
è l'esercito di un impero multietnico appunto.
La propaganda da una parte e dall'altra è sfrenata,
si raccontano atrocità spaventose.
Gli austriaci, si dice,
infilzano i bambini sulle baionette,
sventrano le donne incinte,
bruciano viva la gente.
Ci sono soldati austriaci, si dice, si racconta,
a cui han trovato nello zaino
mani di donna mozzate cariche di anelli.
D'altra parte, ai soldati austriaci
i loro ufficiali spiegano
di stare attenti a non farsi prendere prigionieri
perché ai prigionieri, le donne italiane, cavano gli occhi.
Ora, la cosa interessante
è che queste atrocità sono praticamente tutte inventate.
Nell'Ottocento queste cose,
nelle guerre tra paesi europei,
non succedevano, succedevano pochissimo.
La propaganda invece le inventava.
Se ci pensate, è il contrario
di quello che è poi successo nel ventesimo secolo.
quando le atrocità sono così spaventose
che la propaganda stessa non ci crede,
non le ripete,
lo sterminio degli ebrei, le camera gas.
La gente non ci può neanche credere.
Invece nell'Ottocento è il contrario.
Si inventa di tutto, la gente se lo beve.
Noi oggi sappiamo che in realtà non succedeva,
ma l'odio, l'odio era tangibile.
E dopo cinque giorni Radetzky si rende conto
che deve abbandonare Milano.
Scrive a Vienna
«Questa è la più terribile decisione della mia vita,
ma non posso tenere più a lungo Milano.
Tutto il paese è in rivolta,
perché non è solo Milano e Venezia,
ma sono tutte le città del Lombardo-Veneto
che stanno insorgendo e cacciando le guarnigioni austriache».
Radetzky continua
«Sono minacciato alle spalle dai piemontesi,
perché Carlo Alberto non ha ancora dichiarato guerra,
ma avendo dato lo statuto si sa da che parte sta.
Può approfittarne in qualunque momento.
Possono rompere tutti i ponti alle mie spalle.
Se Radetzky abbandona Milano
dovrà ritirarsi verso Oriente.
Tutti quei fiumi da attraversare.
Non so niente di ciò che accade alle spalle dell'esercito».
Dunque Radetzky abbandona Milano
con la sensazione che ha preso una decisione spaventosa
e che se riesce a salvare il suo esercito,
quel che ne resta, sarà già una bella fortuna.
A Milano si parla di certi ufficiali austriaci
che, se pagati bene,
hanno fatto sapere che loro sono disposti a consegnare Radetzky.
Il governo provvisorio ne discute.
Carlo Cattaneo è l'unico che dice
«Tiriamo fuori i soldi subito!»
Gli altri, ricordate questi nomi dai tempi della scuola
Gabriele Casati, ecco,
gli altri dicono «No, non è una cosa da gentiluomini,
il Radetzky lo prenderemo lo stesso».
E dunque, il 22 marzo Radetzky abbandona Milano,
il 23 marzo Carlo Alberto dichiara guerra.
In tempi normali sarebbe una cosa folle.
L'impero austriaco ha sette volte il numero di abitanti
del Piemonte e del Regno di Sardegna.
Ma è in preda alla rivoluzione.
E poi non solo.
Anche gli altri stati italiani,
un po' credendoci e un po' per forza,
perché la gente ci crede e lo vuole,
anche gli altri sovrani italiani
sono disposti a dare una mano.
La prima guerra di indipendenza
la combatte in sostanza l'esercito sabaudo,
ma in realtà con l'appoggio di contingenti
venuti anche dagli altri stati italiani.
Tutti mandano truppe.
Il Papa Pio IX,
il Granduca di Toscana,
il Re di Napoli.
Tutti mandano truppe per quella
che è sentita come una guerra italiana.
Potrebbe anche diventare qualcosa di più.
Potrebbe diventare una guerra rivoluzionaria,
perché sull'onda di questo movimento
chissà cosa potrebbe succedere.
Ecco, questa è precisamente la cosa
che Carlo Alberto e anche gli altri sovrani
non vogliono.
Perché è una guerra per cacciare gli austriaci
e magari fare una confederazione italiana,
magari un regno d'Italia.
Questo sì, ma la rivoluzione no.
Nessuno la vuole, la rivoluzione.
E così una delle prime cose che succedono
è che Carlo Alberto dichiara guerra.
Da tutta Italia arrivano in folla i volontari
per servire nel suo esercito
e non vengono presi.
Perché armare tutta questa gente
troppo entusiasta,
poi chissà quanti di loro
sono dei rossi pericolosi.
Ecco, non mettiamo il fucile in mano al popolo.
La guerra la farà l'esercito del Re.
Il quale esercito del Re?
La guerra la fa
credendoci, ma con fatica.
Perché anche per l'esercito piemontese
questa storia di fare la guerra per l'Italia
è una cosa mai sentita.
La fanno.
Inalberano il tricolore
che ha una valenza fortissima in quel momento.
Era proibito fino a poco tempo prima
in tutti gli stati italiani.
Carlo Alberto fa accettare al suo esercito
di andare in guerra
col tricolore in testa.
Ma gli ufficiali fra loro si dicono
certo che è tutto diverso
come ci avevano spiegato fino a poco tempo fa.
il duca di Genova
uno dei figli di Carlo Alberto
ci siamo battuti
per una causa grande e generosa
se si vuole
ma totalmente opposta
a tutti i principi
in cui eravamo stati allevati.
Perché l'esercito piemontese
è l'esercito di una monarchia assoluta
della restaurazione
che fino a pochi anni prima
condannava a morte i mazzini e i garibaldi
e gli ufficiali sono ancora quelli
i generali sono ancora quelli
anche i soldati sono quelli
ma i soldati gridano viva l'Italia
senza che nessuno gliel'abbia detto
perché queste parole d'ordine
corrono fra la gente
e all'inizio l'entusiasmo è molto forte.
Dunque i piemontesi
si preparano a invadere il Lombardo Veneto
dietro a Radetzky in ritirata.
Io devo ancora fermarmi un momento
per dirvi due parole
su come sono fatti questi due eserciti
cioè chi sono questi soldati
chi sono i soldati all'epoca
cosa vuol dire essere soldato?
Sono tutti coscritti
che fanno il soldato per forza
volontari che abbiamo voglia
di fare quel mestiere
sì ne trovi qualcuno ma pochi
il grosso dei soldati sono coscritti
c'è la leva obbligatoria
ma non è come il servizio di leva
che molti di noi hanno conosciuto nel novecento
che tutti i giovanotti
o quasi tutti
dovevano fare il loro servizio
gli stati dell'ottocento non hanno i soldi
per avere così tanti soldati
non li vorrebbero neanche
basta che una piccola percentuale
dei giovanotti
faccia il soldato
come si fa a decidere chi lo fa?
semplicissimo se tira a sorte
giovanotti a vent'anni
vanno dal sindaco
tirano il numero
quelli che hanno tirato il numero sbagliato
fanno il servizio militare
a questo punto
ci sono due possibilità
ci sono gli stati
dove i militari dicono
soldati ne vogliamo pochi
ma buoni
per fare un buon soldato
deve restare parecchi anni
questo è quello che viene chiamato
nel gergo dell'epoca
l'esercito di qualità
o l'esercito di caserma
l'esercito austriaco è fatto così
lì i disgraziati
che hanno tirato il numero basso
fanno otto anni di servizio militare
li sbattono in un'altra provincia dell'impero
dove la gente non parla neanche la loro lingua
così l'esercito è una struttura
separata dalla società
che obbedisce soltanto al suo imperatore
i piemontesi seguono l'altra filosofia
che è quella dell'esercito di quantità
che dice ne prendiamo un po' di più
però gli facciamo fare solo un anno
poi li mandiamo a casa
questo politicamente conta molto
la gente è contenta che il servizio militare sia corto
li mandiamo a casa però per un po' di anni
devono tenersi pronti
se c'è la guerra li richiamiamo
quindi mentre l'esercito austriaco
è fatto di soldati di lungo termine
che prestano servizio per anni
Carlo Alberto quando fa la guerra
richiama da casa
un gran numero di riservisti
che si sono fatti il loro unico anno di servizio
poi sono tornati a casa
si sono sposati
hanno trovato un lavoro
e adesso vengono richiamati
scrive Carlo Cattaneo
dal Piemonte fu spinta sul Mincio
a marce forzate
una gente staccata appena dagli aratri e dai telai
male ammaestrata nelle armi
e arrugginita per i lunghi congedi
siccome sappiamo tutti com'è finita questa guerra del 48
non rischio di rovinare la suspense
se vi dico che cominciamo pian pianino a vedere i motivi
per cui si è persa questa guerra
diciamo ancora un'ultima cosa
questi eserciti di riservisti
di contadini
di operai richiamati
potrebbero anche funzionare bene
se ci fossero gli ufficiali per inquadrarli
bisognerebbe avere tanti ufficiali di complemento
richiami i soldati
e richiami anche gli ufficiali
ma pensate alla mentalità dell'epoca
al conflitto sociale
ai privilegi dell'aristocrazia
alla paura che i governi reazionari hanno
nei confronti della borghesia liberale
colta
pericolosa
ufficiali di complemento
chi sarebbero?
eh medici, avvocati, maestri di scuola
quella gente lì
nell'esercito piemontese non la vogliono
quindi i piemontesi richiamano un sacco di soldati
ma hanno pochissimi ufficiali
grossi battaglioni
con tanti uomini
che non sanno bene cosa devono fare
e hanno pochi ufficiali
che gli spiegano cosa devono fare
finalmente
chi comanda questi due eserciti?
li abbiamo già nominati
da una parte c'è Carlo Alberto
a 50 anni
Carlo Alberto è uno di quei nobili piemontesi
di quella generazione che è cresciuta sotto Napoleone
quando il Piemonte era annesso alla Francia
e quella generazione, la stessa di Cavour
che è cresciuta parlando francese
più che italiano
Carlo Alberto è cresciuto a Parigi
sotto Napoleone
ha fatto in tempo a essere nominato tenente
nell'esercito di Napoleone
ma proprio all'ultimo momento
la guerra non l'ha mai fatta
l'ha poi fatta qualche anno dopo
ha partecipato a una guerra in Spagna
dalla parte di quelli che reprimevano
la rivoluzione naturalmente
quindi un po' di esperienza da ufficiale l'ha fatta
ma un esercito non l'ha mai comandato
non ha nessuna idea di cosa si deve fare
e lo vedremo
dall'altra parte invece
per disgrazia di Carlo Alberto
c'è uno che la guerra la sa fare
il felmaresciallo Conte Radetzky
ovvero
Johann Josef Wenzel Graf Radetzky von Radetz
il quale ha 82 anni
in un mondo in cui a 50 anni si è vecchi
e però
non si è dimenticato tutto
avere 82 anni nel 48
vuol dire che Radetzky
era già generale al tempo di Napoleone
ha combattuto ad Austerlitz
a Wagram
comandando delle divisioni
a 82 anni è un po' rallentato
però qualcosa si ricorda ancora
e dunque il 23 marzo scoppia la guerra
Radetzky è appena uscito da Milano
col suo esercito
fiaccato da 5 giorni di macello nelle strade
cosa vuole fare?
ecco quando uno racconta una guerra
la cosa più importante secondo me
è fare in modo che chi ti ascolta
abbia sempre presente
che lì c'è della gente
che vuole fare qualcosa
oppure come Carlo Alberto
che non sa cosa fare
però quella allora è la tragedia
il buon generale vuole sempre fare qualcosa
e ci prova
sapendo che riuscirci sarà difficilissimo
non fosse altro perché hai di fronte qualcuno
il cui unico scopo nella vita
è di impedirti di fare quello che tu vorresti fare
se lo sai però cosa vuoi fare
è già una cosa utile
Radetzky
se ne va da Milano
in che direzione?
qui mi appello di nuovo ai vostri ricordi di scuola
mai sentito parlare del quadrilatero?
ecco cos'è il quadrilatero?
due grandi città fortificate
Verona e Mantova
altre due fortezze
Peschiera e Legnago
quindi una zona sicura
il lago di Garda
che la protegge a nord
di lì non si passa
il Po che la protegge a sud
la valle dell'Adige
per andare in Austria
per avere comunicazioni
ricevere rifornimenti
rinforzi
una posizione strategica perfetta
Radetzky
si dirige in quella direzione
senza sapere cosa troverà
perché le città Lombarde e Venete
stanno tutte insorgendo
senza sapere a ogni momento
se nel prossimo villaggio
i contadini non gli spareranno addosso
con i suoi soldati
che disertano
specialmente i reggimenti italiani
disertano in massa
col terrore che i piemontesi
attraversino il Ticino
e gli arrivino addosso
con un esercito
che in quel momento
sarebbe grande
il triplo del suo
Carlo Alberto dichiara guerra
e non si muove
è questione di ore
di giorni al massimo
già tre giorni dopo
a Milano
fremono
Carlo Alberto
ha mandato a Milano
il generale Passalacqua
e il 25 marzo
scrive da Milano
a Torino
al ministro della guerra
creda eccellenza
che se vogliamo
riuscire a qualcosa
di onorevole
bisogna
assolutamente
che la nostra armata
cerchi il nemico
finalmente
quel 25 marzo
l'avanguardia piemontese
passa il Ticino
ma tutto l'esercito
ci mette cinque giorni
per passarlo
il 29
quando hanno passato
il Ticino
Radetzky
ha già passato l'olio
e ha avuto
buone notizie
non tutte le città
lombarde
sono in sorte
Verona
e Mantova
non sono in sorte
la guarnigione austriaca
tiene
il 2 aprile
Radetzky
entra a Verona
quel giorno
Carlo Alberto
con l'esercito piemontese
è fermo
a Cremona
a 100 chilometri
di lì
e si chiede
cosa deve fare adesso
eh
restare fermi
non si può
ci sono i giornali
che tempestano
l'opinione pubblica
bisogna andare avanti
certo davanti
ci sono le fortezze
del quadrilatero
con l'esercito austriaco
dentro
però noi siamo più forti
poi arrivano i napoletani
arrivano i toscani
arriveranno perfino
quelli del papa
sembra
e dunque
andiamo un po' avanti
piano
il 6-7 aprile
passano l'olio
passato l'olio
però rallentano ancora
perché adesso
sono in paese nemico
e far la guerra
in paese nemico
è difficilissimo
in un paese
straniero
che non conosci
si scopre
al passaggio
dell'olio
che lo stato maggiore
a Torino
non ha preparato
delle carte
del Veneto
non le ha date
neanche ai generali
nessuno
ha una carta
geografica
del paese
dall'olio
in poi
il generale Bava
che comanda
un corpo d'armata
scrive poi
nel suo libro
sulla guerra
non siamo neanche
andati in libreria
a comprarla
e siamo partiti
così in fretta
passato l'olio
non conoscono il paese
per conoscerlo
bisognerebbe avere
della cavalleria leggera
che vada in giro
in ricognizione
a battere la campagna
a chiedere informazioni
l'esercito piemontese
ha dei meravigliosi
reggimenti di corazzieri
di cavalleria pesante
di quella che viene
mandata alla carica
per sfondare tutto
cavalleria leggera
non ne hanno
neanche un reggimento
davanti a loro
ci sono gli austriaci
che hanno la miglior
cavalleria leggera
del mondo
perché loro hanno
gli ungheresi
e quindi gli inventori
degli ussari
hanno i polacchi
inventori dei lanceri
degli ulani
quindi Radetzky
ha un sacco
di cavalleria leggera
che batte il paese
e ovunque
i piemontesi
dove mettono il naso
c'è sempre il terrore
che spuntino
all'improvviso
gli ulani austriaci
da chissà dove
appena passato l'olio
cominciano i casi
di panico
le sentinelle
che si sparano
addosso da sole
i contadini
scambiati
per reggimenti
austriaci
Carlo Alberto
in queste condizioni
va pianino
pianino
fra il 9
e l'11 aprile
si arriva
al Mincio
poi ci sarà
anche l'Adige
cioè non finisce mai
questa cosa
dei fiumi
da passare
però il Mincio
è una cosa seria
perché lì ci sono
pochi ponti
e gli austriaci
per la facciata
soltanto
senza crederci
questi ponti
li difendono
quindi bisogna
sparare qualche
fucilata
per prenderli
ma proprio
pochissime fucilate
e non ci scappa
neanche un morto
però
la presa
di questi tre ponti
viene celebrata
dai giornali italiani
questi tre ponti
si trovano in luoghi
che tutti avete sentito
nominare
perché in tutte
le nostre città
ci sono vie
dedicate a questi luoghi
Goito
vabbè a Goito
si farà poi
anche una battaglia vera
Monzambano
e Valeggio
in questi tre posti
si prendono i ponti
e si passa il Mincio
uno direbbe
no
abbiamo preso i ponti
però andare dall'altra parte
non sappiamo
cosa troviamo
restiamo di qua
non è che qualcuna
di quelle città
potrebbe farci
il piacere di insorgere
Mantua
Verona
dormono
finalmente
arriva la notizia
che a Mantua
i patrioti
preparano
l'insurrezione
lì c'è di Guarnigione
un reggimento italiano
potrebbe unirsi
ai rivoltosi
perciò
si decide
di marciare
verso Mantua
che tra l'altro
è sempre di qua
dal Mincio
così non bisogna
passarlo
si marcia
verso Mantua
qui la principale
cosa che viene fuori
è che
vi leggo direttamente
il generale Bava
in questa spedizione
ci toccò
osservare
come quelle
popolazioni
siano fredde
e poco o nulla
animate
a favore
della causa italiana
inclinando
forse più
verso il tedesco
che ha sempre
cercato
possibilmente
di favoreggiarle
ecco qui
non posso fare
meno di dire
una parola
ma proprio solo una
su questa faccenda
perché come voi
sapete
la reazione
alla retorica
risorgimentale
ha fatto sì
che oggi
sia molto di moda
dire vabbè
ma il risorgimento
in realtà
in Italia
non lo voleva nessuno
la gente
non c'era
i contadini
non c'erano
non ci stavano
ecco
chiaro che
un rapporto
come questo
fa impressione
ma il generale Bava
è impressionato
dal fatto
che i contadini
del Mantovano
sono ostili
perché fin lì
i contadini
lombardi
invece erano insorti
dunque
ancora una volta
il problema
è che il paese
è l'Italia
e non è mai
un paese unito
dove tutti
la pensano
allo stesso modo
ma la cosa interessante
è che già
all'epoca
ecco io dicevo prima
di recente
si mette in discussione
la partecipazione
popolare
italiana
al risorgimento
non è mica vero
già all'epoca
si metteva in dubbio
chi?
i giornali tedeschi
i giornali austriaci
e austriaci
scrivevano
tutta questa rivoluzione
italiana
è un raggiro
dei nobili
di questi quattro gatti
questo è un passo
talmente pazzesco
credo dalla
Frankfurter Zeitung
che ve lo leggo
due righe
tutto il moto
d'Italia
è raggiro
di pochi nobili
di pochi individui
della razza bianca
la quale
opprime
e spolpa
la razza bruna
indigena
delle campagne
d'Italia
costantemente
e vanamente
difesa
dagli amministratori
austriaci
noi a volte
ci dimentichiamo
con che disinvoltura
si parlava di razza
una volta
prima che il nazismo
rendesse impossibile
usare questa terminologia
qui addirittura
i nobili
sono la razza bianca
i contadini
la razza bruna
Carlo Cattaneo
quando l'anno dopo
andrà in esilio
a Parigi
scoprirà
che a Parigi
ci credono
a Parigi
tutti gli dicono
nei salotti
ma sì
ma voi italiani
si sa
questa storia
della patria
della libertà
è una roba
che interessa
a quattro gentiluomini
che hanno viaggiato
e che non ha niente da fare
il popolo italiano
è fatto di lazzaroni
a loro non importa niente
Carlo Cattaneo
frigge
anche perché lui
le ha viste
le strade di Milano
piene di cadaveri
e quindi lo sa
che il popolo
non è tutto
la stessa cosa
un conto
è un popolano
di una città
un conto
è un contadino
di una campagna
cattolica
e ancora
tante altre sfumature
chiuso
non siamo qui
per risolvere
questo problema
ma solo per dirvi
che già allora
ci si scannava
su questo tema
quanto ci credono
gli italiani
nella loro rivoluzione
dunque
stiamo andando
a Mantua
dove dovrebbe
scoppiare
l'insurrezione
e in effetti
i cittadini
sono scesi in piazza
hanno chiesto
le armi
poi è intervenuto
il vescovo
che ha predicato
la calma
e non correre
rischi
i cittadini
hanno detto
beh in fondo
tutto sommato
è vero
sono tornati a casa
Radetzky
ha buttato dentro
un altro reggimento
fine
dell'insurrezione
di Mantua
a questo punto
i piemontesi
si dicono
beh
cosa facciamo
ci sarebbe
sempre peschiera
la prima
delle quattro
fortezze
è peschiera
e la più piccola
la assediamo
sì
assediamo
peschiera
almeno stiamo
facendo qualcosa
capite che
il problema
è che
assediare
le fortezze
è il modo
in cui
si faceva
la guerra
nel settecento
prima che
arrivasse
Napoleone
che ha insegnato
che la guerra
si fa muovendosi
vai a cercare
il nemico
e lo annienti
poi le fortezze
cadono da sole
invece Carlo Alberto
dice no no
assediamo
peschiera
fate venire
l'artiglieria
pesante
dal Piemonte
e l'artiglieria
pesante
da assedio
si mette in movimento
per arrivare
a peschiera
tanto c'è tempo
e invece
non hanno tempo
perché
a Gorizia
un altro
generale austriaco
in Nugent
ha radunato
tutte le guarnigioni
cacciate
dalle varie
città venete
ha reclutato
truppe in Croazia
e adesso
ha un piccolo
esercito
e si prepara
a mettersi
in movimento
verso ovest
per andare
a rafforzare
Radetzky
il Nugent
è un altro
vecchione
un po' meno
a 71 anni
per l'epoca
sono sempre tanti
è un irlandese
al servizio austriaco
fin dalla fine
del settecento
anche lui
ha comandato
degli eserciti
nelle guerre napoleoniche
quello che ha sconfitto
Gioacchino Miurà
adesso è vecchio
però anche lui
il mestiere
lo conosce
il 17 aprile
Nugent
var Calisonzo
visualizzate la cartina
vero
perché si tratta
di movimenti
il 22 aprile
prende Udine
è la prima
grande città veneta
in sorta
che gli austriaci
riconquistano
con la forza
e intanto
Carlo Alberto
aspetta
l'artiglieria
per cominciare
l'assedio
di Peschiera
i suoi gli dicono
ma andiamo
a dare un'occhiata
verso Verona
andiamo a dare
un'occhiata
verso Verona
bisogna passare
anche l'Adige
sono sempre grossi guai
però
c'è un ponte
difeso dagli austriaci
vuol dire proprio
che non vogliono
che passiamo di lì
andiamo
e passiamo
con la forza
questo ponte
si trova in un altro luogo
che tutti avete sentito nominare
Pastrengo
a Pastrengo
a nord di Verona
verso la valle dell'Adige
è importante
perché se gli italiani
sfondano
e bloccano
la strada
fra Verona e Trento
per Radetzky
è una seccatura grossa
quindi la mossa
non è sbagliata
Carlo Alberto
attacca gli austriaci
a Pastrengo
è la prima
vera battaglia
della prima guerra
di indipendenza
e come sapete
è vinta
se no non ci sarebbero
le strade
intitolate via Pastrengo
ecco
gli austriaci
sono la metà
Radetzky
ha sbagliato
a lasciare lì
così tante truppe
in quei casi
o ci metti tutto l'esercito
o non ci metti nessuno
metterci 8.000 uomini
vuol dire farseli mangiare
ci fosse stato Napoleone
davanti
quegli 8.000 uomini
se li mangiava tutti
Carlo Alberto
non è Napoleone
attacca
pianino
quando sembra
che si metta male
c'è la famosa carica
dei carabinieri a cavallo
uno squadrone
cento uomini
caricano
gli austriaci
si ritirano
la battaglia
di Pastrengo
è finita
i piemontesi
hanno avuto
15 morti
e 90 feriti
lo 0,7%
delle forze
impegnate
gli austriaci
che hanno perso
hanno avuto
il 5%
di perdite
perché vi dico
questo
che può sembrare
una cosa sgradevole
stare qui a dire
u che ridicoli
hanno fatto pochi morti
ma se si racconta
una guerra
bisogna raccontarla
con i termini
delle guerre
nelle battaglie
di Napoleone
era normale
che ognuno
dei due eserciti
perdesse
in un giorno
di battaglia
il 20
il 25%
degli uomini
impegnati
spaventoso
ma se a Pastrengo
Carlo Alberto
perde lo 0,7%
dei suoi uomini
e l'intera forza
austriaca
si ritira
davanti a lui
invece di essere
mangiata
vuol dire
una sola cosa
che da una parte
e dall'altra
ci vanno
molto prudenti
sia i generali
sia le truppe
non fanno
un passo
di troppo
sparano
ci fermiamo
intanto
sono arrivati
i cannoni
finalmente
si comincia
l'assedio
di Peschiera
e sono arrivati
anche i soldati
del Papa
al comando
del generale
Durando
un vecchio
generale
non generale
un vecchio
rivoluzionario
piemontese
che ha combattuto
nelle guerre civili
di mezza Europa
tipo bizzarro
per fare il generale
del Papa
ma il Papa
non ha generali
ha dovuto
assumerne uno
e ha preso
questo Durando
che sembrava
se ne intendesse
Durando
arriva al Po
dall'Emilia Romagna
con un piccolo esercito
una divisione regolare
pontificia
e una divisione
di volontari romani
c'è davvero
tutta Italia
appena Durando
è arrivato
al Po
con le truppe pontifice
Pio IX
cambia idea
il 29 aprile
Pio IX
dichiara
ufficialmente
che i cardinali
gli hanno spiegato
che il Papa
non può partecipare
a una guerra
fratricida
contro una potenza
cattolica
e quindi
le sue truppe
si devono ritirare
ma per fortuna
è il 48
e nel 48
succedono
le cose più incredibili
il generale Durando
comandante
dell'esercito
del Papa
decide che lui
disobbedisce
al Papa
e quindi
rimane lì
e anzi
passa
molto lentamente
il Po
e si inoltra
nel Veneto
potrebbe andare
a sbarrare
la strada
a Nugent
che viene giù
da Udine
è arrivato
a Feltre
Belluno
sta scendendo
sempre più giù
scende verso Treviso
Durando sale
con l'esercito
pontificio
dipende
da chi
è più bravo
dei due
gli sbarra
la strada
oppure
l'altro
è più bravo
e riesce
a superarlo
Nugent
71 anni
che però
ha comandato
degli eserciti
al tempo
di Napoleone
Durando
che è molto più
giovane
rivoluzionario
ne ha fatte
di tutti i colori
ma un esercito
non l'ha mai comandato
non c'è niente
da fare
Nugent
passa
Durando
non lo trova
Nugent
passa oltre
il 25 maggio
Radetzky
a Verona
riceve i rinforzi
i piemonteggi
sono sempre fermi
ad assediare
Peschiera
Radetzky
non è Napoleone
ma sa fare la guerra
appena ricevuti
i rinforzi
attacca
il 27 maggio
esce da Verona
la sera
ora di nuovo
lo so che era più facile
se vi portavo una cartina
ma tanto quelli in fondo
non la vedevano
lo stesso
pensate a com'è fatta
la pianura padana
i piemontesi
hanno la sinistra
a Pastrengo
sull'Adige
la destra
davanti a Mantova
è un fronte
di 70 chilometri
è un'epoca
in cui non c'è
nella radio
né il telefono
non c'è niente
gli ordini
li mandi
con uno a cavallo
un esercito
schierato
su un fronte
di 70 chilometri
è troppo disperso
Radetzky
decide di attaccare
all'estremità
verso Mantova
attacca
davanti a Mantova
c'è una divisione
toscana
con due battaglioni
napoletani
c'è il famoso
battaglione degli studenti
universitari
di Pisa
sono tutti schierati
fra due paesini
che anche questi
li avete sempre sentiti
nominare
Curtatone
e Montanara
ora la storia
di Curtatone
e Montanara
si può raccontare
in molti modi
l'eroica resistenza
dei toscani
che resistono
un giorno intero
fermando
l'avanzata
di Radetzky
che altrimenti
da sud
avrebbe preso
alle spalle
i piemontesi
si può anche raccontare
dicendo che già
il giorno prima
il generale Bava
piemontese
aveva avvertito
il comandante toscano
che Radetzky
stava arrivando
dicendogli
fate qualcosa
e secondo il generale Bava
il generale toscano
Deloget
non aveva fatto niente
si può anche raccontare
la versione
del generale toscano
Deloget
il quale dice
i piemontesi
mi hanno detto
che arrivavano
gli austrieci
aspettavo che venissero
aiutarmi
non si sono mossi
i piemontesi
morale
eroico combattimento
degli studenti pisani
ma la divisione toscana
viene sbaragliata
scappa fino a Brescia
e non ne esce più
Radetzky
ha passato
il fondo
dello schieramento
italiano
e può prendere
sul fianco
i piemontesi
Carlo Alberto
raduna
quello che riesce
a radunare
una parte
dell'esercito
perché è troppo
sparpagliato
viene giù
incontro a Radetzky
era meglio
magari se si fermava
trovava una linea
ma non importa
viene giù lo stesso
e lì
lì si vede
che dopo tutto
neanche Radetzky
è Napoleone
c'è un combattimento
confuso
nessuno capisce molto
nessuno ha il coraggio
di andare troppo dentro
è la battaglia di Goito
quella vera
prima avevamo solo
preso il ponte
questa è la battaglia
di Goito
commemorata
nei nomi
delle nostre vie
Radetzky
dopo un pomeriggio
di combattimenti
incerti
decide che non si passa
non ce l'ha fatta
gli è andata male
torna indietro
qui si vede bene
che anche lui
partecipa ormai
di questa mentalità
per cui non si va
troppo a fondo
perché Radetzky
alla battaglia di Goito
quanti morti ha avuto
ve lo dico dopo
i piemontesi
hanno avuto 45 morti
e 260 feriti
l'uno per cento
delle perdite
ma in Italia
naturalmente
quello che conta
è che la battaglia
è vinta
Radetzky aveva attaccato
e lo abbiamo fermato
l'esercito di Carlo Alberto
si è salvato
i giornali italiani
scrivono
della grande vittoria
Carlo Cattaneo
a Milano
legge i giornali
ed è disgustato
lui ormai è uscito
dal governo provvisorio
da sinistra
e segue
la propaganda
governativa
italiana
con orrore
Carlo Cattaneo
dopo la battaglia
di Goito
a Milano
il governo
vanissimo
e ignorante
annunciò
che il nemico
era fuggito
dirottamente
lasciando
5.000 morti
gli austriaci
a Goito
ebbero 68 morti
però è una vittoria
e il giorno dopo
Peschiera si arrende
sono le regole della guerra
il comandante di Peschiera
sapeva
arriva Radetzky
se arriva a soccorrermi
io tengo
se Radetzky è battuto
io ho fatto il mio dovere
e ho il diritto
di arrendermi
salvare i miei uomini
Peschiera si arrende
e i soldati
gridano a Carlo Alberto
viva il re d'Italia
non basta
arriva la notizia
che qualche giorno prima
a Vienna
è scoppiata di nuovo
la rivoluzione
e può anche darsi
che Radetzky
venga richiamato
a Vienna
con le truppe
per sparare
sugli studenti
dunque
apparentemente
non potrebbe
andare meglio
cosa si fa?
si sta fermi
naturalmente
cercando di decidere
qual è la cosa
migliore da fare
cosa fa Radetzky?
Radetzky dice
l'unica cosa
che non posso fare
è star fermo
mi muovo
mi è andata male di qua
torno indietro
ci sono le città venete
in sorte
c'è Durando
con i pontifici
andiamo a occuparci
un po' di loro
Radetzky
fulmineamente
marcia su Vicenza
quindi torna indietro
a Vicenza
arriva Durando
con i pontifici
la posizione è fortissima
Durando garantisce
qui possiamo tenere
anche otto giorni
intanto
i piemontesi
possono passare
finalmente il mincio
e anche l'Adige
magari
attaccare Radetzky
alle spalle
Durando
manda un messaggio
di questo tipo
io sto qua
fermo
otto giorni
garantito
venite
il primo giorno
Radetzky attacca
sbaraglia
i pontifici
Durando
si arrende
chiede
l'armistizio
firma una convenzione
per cui si ritira
al di là del Po
e si impegna
a non partecipare
più alla guerra
per tre mesi
piemontesi
tutte le città venete
tranne Venezia
sono riconquistate
dagli austriaci
segue un mese
durante il quale
nessuno fa niente
Radetzky
aspetta rinforzi
ha già fatto abbastanza
Carlo Alberto
non sa cosa fare
il re di Napoli
lo sa
ritira le poche truppe
che aveva mandato
a Milano
si scopre
un nuovo problema
la guerra
la stanno facendo
solo i piemontesi
non c'è un esercito
lombardo
dobbiamo assolutamente
mandare un esercito
lombardo
reclutiamo volontari
il clima è già un po'
cambiato anche a Milano
si trovano pochi
volontari
allora il governo
provvisorio
di Milano
stabilisce
che è un governo
quindi ha il diritto
di richiamare
i soldati in congedo
gli ex soldati
austriaci
in congedo
certo
hanno sempre
l'obbligo
di obbedire al governo
vengono richiamati
non ci sono divise
li mandano al fronte
senza divisa
arrivati al fronte
vengono a sapere
che gli austriaci
fucilano
quelli trovati
col fucile in mano
senza divisa
quindi le truppe milanesi
dichiarano che loro
finché non gli danno
una divisa
non combattono
allora a Milano
vanno a vedere
nei magazzini
sono pieni
di divise austriache
decidono di vestire
le truppe milanesi
con divise austriache
ma per fortuna
non ce n'è abbastanza
quindi i soldati
partono vestiti
come vogliono loro
scrive Carlo Cattaneo
che ormai si mette
le mani nei capelli
vestiti con giubbotti
di tela
i più con berretto
alcuni con cappelli
di feltro
di paglia
di ogni foggia
reggimenti informi
che parevano
agli stipendi
del più pitocco
popolo del globo
però le truppe
arrivano al fronte
i giornalisti insistono
bisogna fare qualcosa
Carlo Alberto
è tormentato
eppure l'occasione
ci sarebbe
il 4 luglio
Carlo Alberto
ha il colpo di fortuna
della sua vita
arriva
a proporsi
al suo servizio
il più grande
generale italiano
di tutti i tempi
Garibaldi
arriva Garibaldi
che è venuto dritto
dall'America
con un po' di uomini
per partecipare
alla rivoluzione italiana
il 4 luglio
si presenta a Carlo Alberto
offrendogli la sua spada
Carlo Alberto
scrive al ministro
della guerra
ho concesso oggi
udienza
al celebre
generale
Garibaldi
dice
mi ha offerto
il suo aiuto
suo e dei suoi amici
tutti questi rossi
continua la citazione
dalla lettera
di Carlo Alberto
i precedenti
di questi signori
e specialmente
del sedicente generale
il suo famoso
proclama repubblicano
ci rendono
assolutamente
impossibile
accettarli
nell'esercito
si potrebbe
forse
dar loro
un sussidio
purché si tolgano
dai piedi
di conseguenza
Garibaldi
viene cacciato
l'esercito
è sempre disteso
su 70 chilometri
da Pastrengo
a Mantua
dal Mincio
al Po
non funziona niente
non funziona
il servizio
dei viveri
i soldati
muoiono di fame
in mezzo alle province
più ricche d'Europa
fa un caldo
da morire
letteralmente
le divise
sono di panno
pesante
non si conosce
niente di igiene
contro la calura
del sole
non si contano
le notizie
di soldati
ufficiali
che muoiono
di sincope
in campo
sotto il sole
Radetzky
aspetta
di ricevere
rinforzi
e poi si muove
il 29 luglio
viene avanti
comincia a tastare
in vari punti
scopre che i piemontesi
sono deboli a nord
sull'adige
attacca
sfonda
li mette in fuga
viene avanti
corre un rischio
perché la parte destra
dell'esercito piemontese
dove c'è Carlo Alberto
è ancora lì
potrebbe attaccarlo
sul fianco
lo attacca
Radetzky
sta salendo
verso occidente
e Carlo Alberto
lo attacca da sud
fra il Mincio
e l'Adige
vicino ai ponti
del Mincio
in un posto
chiamato
Custoza
in realtà
se uno guarda
sulla cartina
questi eserciti
sono molto grandi
rispetto al territorio
non è che stanno
tutti in un paesino
la battaglia
si svolge
su un vasto territorio
ma Custoza
è il posto simbolico
Carlo Alberto
attacca
come al solito
ormai
lo abbiamo capito
attacca
con poca convinzione
poco convinto
i soldati
nessuno ha voglia
di farsi ammazzare
combattono
per un paio
di giorni
poi si rendono
conto
che non passano
Radetzky
ha vinto
come al solito
nella battaglia
di Custoza
si è giocato
più truppe
ha avuto
più perdite
ha perso
il 5%
del suo esercito
non è mai
una battaglia
napoleonica
lo vedete
Napoleone
perdeva il 20%
pur di non
smettere
e continuare
questi si fermano
prima
Carlo Alberto
ha perso
il 2%
si ferma
e Radetzky
non si ferma
ha vinto
benissimo
andiamo avanti
passa lui
il mincio
verso Occidente
e le strade
che collegano
l'esercito
di Carlo Alberto
alla madre patria
al Piemonte
e quelle strade
sono lì
gli austrici
ci arrivano sopra
ci tagliano
la ritirata
cosa tragica
davvero
per un esercito
che non può
vivere
se non ha
una linea
di collegamento
con la patria
da cui arrivano
le notizie
i rinforzi
i soldi
tutto
dunque la situazione
è drammatica
Carlo Alberto
chiede l'armistizio
27 luglio
Radetzky
è talmente stupefatto
che questi
alla prima sconfitta
gli offrono già
l'armistizio
che non chiede
quasi niente
gli basta che
i piemontesi
si ritirino
dietro l'Adda
potrebbero tenere
Milano quindi
è un'offerta
straordinaria
Carlo Alberto
dice mai
mai accetterò
condizioni così
vergognose
la guerra
continua
di conseguenza
si ritirano
però
passano il Mincio
fanno saltare
il ponte di Goito
27 luglio
passano il Mincio
28 luglio
passano l'Oglio
all'andata
ci avevano messo
una settimana
al ritorno
ci mettono
un giorno
31 luglio
passano l'Adda
lasciando dietro
di sé
un paese
terrorizzato
perché tutto
il paese
era insorto
e adesso
hanno tutti
il terrore
delle rappresaglie
adesso tornano
gli austriaci
Cremona
è quasi
abbandonata
dagli abitanti
indietro
rimangono solo
i malati
tantissimi
non hanno abbastanza
ospedali
non hanno medici
innumerevoli
soldati malati
sono lasciati indietro
si spera
di resistere
sull'Adda
ma gli austriaci
sono più bravi
il primo agosto
passano anche l'Adda
a questo punto
Carlo Alberto
tanto per cambiare
deve decidere
cosa fare
torno in Piemonte
e non se ne parla più
non sia mai
difenderò Milano
Carlo Alberto
decide di marciare
su Milano
e difenderla
e qui si è discusso
moltissimo
perché ovviamente
le fonti
diciamo così
monarchiche
dicono
l'atto eroico
del re
che decide
di sacrificarsi
col suo esercito
per salvare Milano
poi ci sono quelli
che dicono
sì
aveva una gran paura
che scoppiasse la rivoluzione
a Milano
alla notizia che il re
aveva perso la guerra
aveva una gran paura
che proclamassero
la repubblica
a Milano
perciò preferisce
andarci lui
con l'esercito
fatto sta
che ci va
e questa estate
è caldissima
pazzesca
la sera
del 2 agosto
c'è un uragano
con grandine
così grossa
che ammazza
uomini e cavalli
i soldati si ritirano
da giorni
senza niente da mangiare
in condizioni
disastrose
il 3 agosto
arrivano a Milano
e trovano
una popolazione
ostile
perché a Milano
ormai si sono detti
il re
ci sta per mollare
il clima
non è più quello
e comunque
i piemontesi
si trincerano
in quella
che oggi è
parte di Milano
e allora
era una remota
periferia
di Cascinali
per il piacere
dei milanesi
lo dico
la linea di difesa
va da Chiesa Rossa
al Vigentino
al Corvetto
fino a Calvairate
ci si schiera lì
il 3 agosto
sperando di difendere Milano
il giorno dopo
Radetzky non perde tempo
il 4 agosto
Radetzky attacca
dopo un giorno
di combattimenti
Carlo Alberto
si arrende
dichiara che non ha viveri
non ha munizioni
i milanesi poi
sosterranno
non è vero
la città era piena di viveri
era piena di munizioni
piena di gente
pronta a combattere
Carlo Alberto
preferisce arrendersi
chiede l'armistizio
a questo punto
però Milano
la deve cedere
le condizioni
che aveva rifiutato
pochi giorni prima
sarebbero state
da leccarsi i baffi
invece no
l'armistizio
vuol dire
i piemontesi
tornano in Piemonte
Milano
viene ceduto
agli austriaci
i primi popolani
milanesi
che arrivano
dalle barricate
in periferia
in centro
dove c'è la folla
in piazza
e dicono alla folla
il re si è arreso
Milano
è ceduto
agli austriaci
vengono linciati
dalla folla
che non ci crede
crede che siano spie
austria
che provocatori
a Milano
si suonano le campane
a martello
si arma la gente
ma
ma intanto
gli austriaci
stanno entrando
c'è un momento
in cui non si sa
cosa può succedere
perché l'esercito
piemontese
è in periferia
e il re
invece
è in centro
è a palazzo
greppi
praticamente da solo
con pochi aiutanti
e fuori c'è la folla
che urla
passa qualche ora
durante le quale
può succedere di tutto
può succedere
che i milanesi
invadano il palazzo
e impicchino
Carlo Alberto
al balcone
come può succedere
che le truppe piemontesi
in periferia
che sono informate
di quello che sta succedendo
attacchino Milano
e la mettano
a ferro e fuoco
per salvare il loro re
poi invece
per miracolo
si evita il peggio
arriva un gruppetto
di bersaglieri
recupera Carlo Alberto
lo porta fuori Milano
e l'esercito
se ne va
e gli austriaci
rientrano in Milano
e insomma
il peggio è evitato
ma appunto
peggio di così
non poteva andare
il 9 agosto
si firma
l'armistizio di Salasco
la guerra è durata
quattro mesi e mezzo
immediatamente dopo
questa è l'ultimissima cosa
con cui chiudo
la notizia arriva a Vienna
dove la rivoluzione è finita
era un fuoco di paglia
sono tutti tranquilli
arriva la notizia
della grande vittoria
di Radetzky
e Johann Strauss
per festeggiare
compone quel pezzo
che noi tutti gli anni
al concerto di Capodanno
ascoltiamo con tanto piacere
la marcia di Radetzky
che non viene composta
per Capodanno
ma a tamburo battente
in pochi giorni
l'armistizio del 9 agosto
il 31 agosto
a Vienna
va la prima
della marcia di Radetzky
grazie
grazie a tutti